So I would like to--
So today, I'm going to present an investigator-initiated trial
led by my colleague, Dr. Ajay Noonkar,
evaluating the role of belantemab, pomalidomide,
and dexamethasone as maintenance therapy
post-transplant and high-risk myeloma patients.
These are my disclosures.
So as we've heard over and over again in this conference,
patients with high-risk disease have
poor progression-free survival and overall survival
as compared to standard-risk disease.
The figure on the right here is from our RVD1000 data set.
Long-term follow-up revealed a drastic difference
in the median progression-free survival and overall survival
in standard-risk disease versus high-risk.
So this truly highlights an unmet need patient population.
However, with modern-day therapies and induction
approaches, it is now feasible to attain
deep responses with high rates of MRD
negativity in even the high-risk patient population.
However, the master trial revealed
that when patients with high-risk disease
went on to the MRD--
achieved MRD sure and went on to surveillance of treatment,
the patients with more high-risk chromosomal abnormalities
had a two-year incidence of progression of almost 47%,
which tells us that fixed-duration therapy is
probably not applicable to this group.
So multiple different combination maintenance
strategies have been explored in this patient population
in the maintenance setting.
We published our own experience with a triplet maintenance
RVD a few years back, which revealed a median PFS
of about 32 months in high-risk patients
post-transplant or post-induction.
Similarly, ELO RVD maintenance showed similar PFS rates.
Cafirzomib and Revlimid maintenance was explored
in the four days.
We also published a daily trial, and it revealed a median PFS
of about 42 months in the high-risk patient population.
We also published our experience with KPD maintenance,
Cafirzomib, Parm, and Dex, which showed actually
a median PFS of 62 months, which is kind of unheard of
in this high-risk patient population.
And then other trials, like Optimum trial,
and have been exploring other combination strategies
with some promising responses.
As my prior speakers, Dr. Martin and others,
have already alluded to the DREAM study,
the Algonquin study actually first
evaluated this combination of Belantem and Parm/Dex
and showed that this combination was safe and efficacious.
And then these findings were further
corroborated in the large phase III randomized control trial,
the DREAM-8 study, where this combination was compared
head-to-head with EVD or Parm/Velcate/Dex and showed pretty
impressive results.
So this was a very, very impressive study.
It showed very impressive PFS rates of 71% at 12 months
as compared to 51% in the standard of care arm.
And this benefit was noted across all of the subgroups
pretty much.
And then, of course, as we heard,
the major limitation in using Belantem/Parm/Velcate/Dex
is the incidence of ocular toxicity.
And in the DREAM-8 study, we basically saw that there was
20 over 50 in about 34% of the patients.
And 1% of the patient actually had worsening to 20 over 200.
The median time to onset of this toxicity
was about 112 days, which is about 16 weeks.
And then the median duration of this toxicity
was about four weeks, or 29 days.
And the important point to note is that 90% of these patients
actually had reversal of this toxicity.
And I would like to highlight that the dose of Belantem/Parm/Velcate/Dex
used in the DREAM-8 study was actually 2.5 milligrams per day.
The dose of Belantem/Parm/Velcate/Dex
was actually 1.9 milligrams per kilogram every four weeks
for the first cycle.
And then subsequently, it was a use
at a dose of 1.9 milligrams per kilogram every four weeks.
So this brings us to our IIT, where
we use a combination of Belantem/Parm/Velcate/Dex
in high-risk, newly diagnosed myeloma patients
post-transplant.
High-risk was defined as presence of DEL17, PET414, or 1416,
and then DEL18.
And then the DEL18 was defined as presence of DEL18.